so this shit's crazy this this over the
past couple weeks
or what's it been like 10 days now
ludwig
yeah um the streamer
ludwig is a streamer uh the streamer
actually i had a funny interaction with
him i
because i started playing geo gaster on
my second channel
you ever played that uh i have not
so it drops you down in a random
location on google maps yeah yeah yeah
like i've watched i've watched geo
wizard and stuff yeah
yeah okay so he ludwig i guess was doing
it on a stream for like a while
and him and geo wizard played together
and i saw that and i wanted to play with
geo i actually
thought of it i was sitting at my desk
i'm like oh i should try and collab with
geowizard and i was like
on his profile trying to figure out how
to do it couldn't figure it out didn't
see the
about page has had his email address in
there whatever so then i googled
collabing with geowizard to see if
anyone else had done it and ludwig
did it and so i hit him up and i was
like i just
hit him on twitter i'm like yo what's
good i followed him and i was like yo
what's good man
and he was like what's up and i was like
uh hey how did you collab with geowizard
and he was like i just emailed him and
was like a little bit
like just like not i mean it wasn't cold
but he just was like
almost like insulted i guess and then in
his stream he was like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing trying to steal my [ __ ]
he hits me up
just out just to ask me how i collab
with geo wizard
so i felt kind of bad about that so
shout out ludwig i actually i love your
[ __ ] and i did copy you a little bit and
i'm i'm sorry about that but
um anyway so he's he did this subathon
on twitch
yeah and are subathons like normal
events
like he did he just invented the clock
thing where
every time someone subs it adds time
onto his stream that
that part i don't know um as far as i
know
he he is the first to do that i i'm
pretty sure
because you know there's like 24 hour
streams but yeah i think that was his
idea to to do the clock and just keep
increasing the time
um i was actually gonna say apparently
ludwig raided my music project like a b
or something on his tier list okay
and then like uh i i don't know where i
like i haven't seen it
uh anywhere because i know he has a
video like rating youtuber music but i
just one day in stream like a bunch of
people came in and were just like
spamming my chat with like
ludwig rated you a b ludwig i'm like
what are you guys talking about
like he rated your music at b i'm like
you you realize
without context that makes no [ __ ]
sense that's the worst kind of
comment it's like a streamer chat like
as it's going on comment where people
are just like
completely out of context like like
santana said this and
then you're like what what what do you
mean give me a little bit where do i
even start what do i google
to find this like give me a little
morsel of information more than just
yeah um anyway yeah so
he's he's been doing this 24 hour stream
a subathon
her stream and uh every time someone
subs it increases the time on it and
he's still going no or did it finally
end i i don't know i think
maybe he is still going but he's now the
most subbed
he's still good streamer most active
subs on twitch by like
200 percent like he has like over double
the next most subbed twitch streamers
subs
he made like a million bucks or
something like that or 500 000
or something so crazy luke bring up the
tick tock breaking down the money
is that what it is um
i mean i wonder it also is like
i think twitch does different
um revenue splits
with some streamers i think some
streamers have like exclusive revenue
splits
so i wonder if he's maybe in that
category i don't know
so he's getting more money from it i'm i
don't know i don't know i don't i don't
want to put that out there and
like start a rumor at it off of nothing
i just know that some larger streamers
have
special splits um
yeah he's still going luke said he said
got the photos ready
wait is that is that of
he's got it here oh luke can you pull
that up manny
okay guys ludwig has been streaming for
over 21 days at this point
as you can see there's only a minute
left but because this is a subathon
whenever somebody subs
it goes up another 10 seconds so this
thing's not going anywhere
time for some quick math ludwig makes
about three dollars for a sub we
multiply that by six to get minutes
60 to get hours and 519 because that's
how many hours he's been streaming
and that puts us at a grand total of 560
thousand dollars a lot of which is going
to charity and like i said earlier just
because it's at one minute doesn't mean
it's ending soon
chad has already added 15 minutes since
i started filming this video
ludwig is not leaving the stream until
the end of the month kind of [ __ ]
it's kind of [ __ ] genius although
that's so annoying streaming everything
like that's just so
yeah black mirror like yeah man i give i
give him a lot of
props for having the uh mental resolve
to do that
you know granted he's splitting up the
stream he's doing a lot of cool stuff in
that way
um but still it's a it's a lot of work
yeah and i think there's something to be
said about uh
24-hour streams and the future
of like always running in entertainment
yeah and i think this this is a good
example that i found
pull up that tick tock that i sent this
morning luke this is a 24 7 stream of a
stop
sign in a neighborhood have you seen
this
no that's the perfect form of
entertainment for
me it's like people like if someone
rolls through
like just rolls through it the chat will
be like oh [ __ ] we got a badass
[Music]
is there that much activity going on in
that thing
i guess there was yeah this tick tock is
uh
luke can you pull it up no can you pull
down can you
look can you pull it up please all right
man can you pull that up please
permit the frog if you're ever bored if
you want to do something fun with your
life there's this twitch account i found
where it's just a stop sign in a
neighborhood
and a lot of the cars do not stop at it
and
everyone in chat kind of like competes
with each other like who is this next
car going to go
is this next car going to stop it's
pretty entertaining and then even some
of the viewers show up to the stream and
you know
do fun stuff i don't know it's pretty
cool so if you want to check out the
stream
feel free it's 24 7 but yeah i thought
it'd be pretty cool
it's kind of genius it's kind of [ __ ]
genius
that's crazy and i know there was like a
website a long time ago of like a bar
line
or sorry sorry it was a stream it was a
24-hour stream
of a line like of a outside of a bar
basically nice
so you could watch like drunk people in
line which is a little bit creepy
actually
it was like from an apartment window
yeah
but public place right
i guess so that's that that's just gonna
be um
weird when someone creates a network
based on like all like public facing
cameras like i bet someone has to have
done that already
i feel like that's like some weird
hacker project to hack like a bunch of
security cameras and be like i created a
a micro network where you just go to a
channel and you can watch a random
security camera around the world
what movie is that in that's in a movie
that's how fast and furious isn't it
no yeah where they take like what
[ __ ] movie is that it's some like
mainstream action movie where they take
the guy hacks into like all the cctv
cameras
minority and they figure out where the
dew is the dude is because like like
geo-locate him
no i mean i think that's serious i think
that's every now
brother i know that movie front to back
there ain't no camera hacking in that
film i mean one of them
oh maybe yeah mate but the original
no yeah yeah not the original yeah every
every action movie's done that but
i just mean like i i bet that's coming
if it's not there already [ __ ] like
you know
camerawatch.org and you're just creeping
on people
yeah yeah yeah 24 hour streams is
definitely gonna be
i think the move i mean it basically
happens with you know
grand theft auto role play i feel that
that's probably the first example of
like 24-hour entertainment
consistency so what what is the deal now
what's the current status with gta role
play how big is it
well i think one of the most known
servers i don't want to say if it's like
the biggest or whatever because i don't
really
but one of the most known servers is the
no pixel server
um xqc was like recently banned from it
and a lot of streamers get on there
hassan hit me up to get on no pixel but
i just don't have the time required to
be
on no pixel it's like a lot of hours you
got to put in you got to create like a
backstory for your character
and all this and that so um
and then are basically playing d like is
it
are you trying to be funny is it like
improv like are people trying to be
entertaining are they just trying to be
a really good
police officer or whatever they are yeah
i mean it just depends
it's honestly it's like a weird form of
like method acting like
you're just trying to be the most
convincing and entertaining character
that could be
a lot of different ways you could be a
cop and really own the role and
be a dick cop and maybe you're
entertaining because like you ticket
everybody and like you you're an [ __ ]
or maybe you
break bad and you're like a double agent
it's crazy dude
it's just proof that like once vr is
actually a thing and we're all kind of
plugged into the matrix like people are
just they just want a second life they
don't actually want a
cool life yeah they just want a second
like i want to try and just
manage uh chili's that's my
what are you in your second life were
you like a king are you some sort of
you know mute like maybe you're a rapper
or like uh it's like no i actually just
no
i managed the chili's on on 5th street
and i actually just um i own an olive
oil
service local to like this minecraft
server
and i just sell olive oil yeah
oh okay yeah i got three cats um they're
a little bit annoying
um you know i uh haven't really quite
settled down yet i haven't found the
right person but i'm not really putting
myself out there enough
you know because the cats take so much
time so
um other than that i do i like to vacuum
in my spare time
[Laughter]
yeah bro role play is is
super crazy um i just think from an
entertainment
standpoint and if more people got it
like
i don't i think if it wasn't presented
in gta it would be like a spectacle
for people i feel like that it the fact
that it occurs within grand theft auto i
think people go
uh that's weird because it's a game but
like they don't see it as a
kind of like a bridging thing like if
if someone built like a world that was
identical to gta but just wasn't branded
as that and then if you knew
like oh yeah there's like this weird
second life
you know like the game second life or
whatever where people just go in
and perform and just do that i think
people would tune into that [ __ ]
no question yeah so
yeah i was listening to a podcast today
and they were talking about gta like
i didn't realize that people on gta
radio stations
songs get more streams there than they
do on real radio stations
in some in some cases interesting
interesting
it's that's crazy like the games there's
stuff within games
now like
kids playing roblox and stuff like that
have such a
deeper understanding of like nfts
and and cryptocurrency because they've
been dealing with virtual currency for
the last like four years playing roblox
yeah like they understand they
understand that [ __ ]
so much more yeah wild yeah that's the
that's the one thing i was actually
talking to my dad about this that i
think
we can get into [ __ ] jimmy fallon and
all that in a second
yeah but i feel the thing that i feel
why big media companies are slipping and
they're not cool and they're not
relevant
is what they don't get is that all the
people younger than them
you know 12 11 whatever they
understand technology and everything
like way
better than they will possibly ever
understand it because like they grew up
in a certain context where
it's just sort of normal and their brain
is just waiting for the next thing
and like i i hate [ __ ] the thing i
hate about nfts
is an older person like like an investor
person is shilling for it and pretending
they really get it when they
they don't [ __ ] it's blowing their
mind to even talk about it but like they
like to put on this face like oh yeah
nfts it's the future it's like why is it
the future
blockchain and you know it's like
the future yeah yeah yeah whereas kids
you ask an eight-year-old and he's like
oh it totally makes sense
tokenizing stuff i mean yeah i i own a
piece of this sword with this other kid
and we
yeah you know we sell it after we borrow
it to this guy and then we take
interest on our token payments and
you're like what yeah
yeah and the investor is like yeah see
it's the future my kid
talks about it all the time you know i
actually got into it because my kid he's
playing roblox all the time and he's
like dad this is just like roblox i'm
like
that's it dude that's that's the thing
is like i'm going to be that i know i'm
going to be that
in five to whatever years you know five
months
yeah when i remember like this this c
yeah exactly
in five months the um my ceo my first
ceo out of college i was working for a
startup right and he was always
quoting what his kids were saying
talking about we got to do more market
research because my kids are doing this
my kids are playing this my kid and i
always just think like just
do it yourself i don't understand like
download roblox and just play it
yeah but now this this week i'm hanging
with
like my uh one of kelsey's family or
whatever he's eight
right so i'm watching him use youtube
and roblox and i'm leaning over the
screen like you know what
you know what i can say like one weird
example one one
weird example is he was watching a laser
beam video right it's one of these one
of these fortnite videos that has 45
million views
yeah it's the fortnite compilation of
laser beam playing fortnite
yeah and you me i would sit there on
youtube like how does this have 45
million views like
it's got like a million likes or
something like that and yet he this is
like the 50th time he's watched this
video and he's scrolling to all the
parts that he knows by heart
by time stamp of the best kills in the
thing and i'm like that just blows my
[ __ ] mind yeah
i mean that i mean that's like
i think what's the interesting thing is
we grew up
where we couldn't control media and so
if we went to watch a movie
or whatever that was it it was like we
got it the one time
and we had to store it all up here and
then just talk about it for forever
and i think that's a super weird thing
where kids get to like
no i want it i want the kill i want the
one
give me the ipad i want to watch the one
you know i don't know that
that bugs me out it's just
and watching them play roblox i'm like
are you like cause i'm like this
company that their market cap now is
like what 70 billion
or something crazy right they went
public they're doing really well so i'm
like sitting there trying
i'm like do you have fun playing this
game he's like not really
i was like okay how often do you play
he's like man every day
like i just don't i can't even begin to
why do you play it then
he's like it's like kind of fun look i
can do this and i can do this and i'm
like are you playing with anyone else
he's like yeah i'm gonna serve her with
this random weirdo
i'm [ __ ] so so far removed from this
why are you doing something that's not
fun